I was a huge spender big spender and a
lot of friends at the bigger firms I
always liked nice things I always was
not scared to work for nice things I was
out of my [ __ ] mind so my mom said
rich people are greedy my dad said poor
people are lazy and I'm in the middle
did you always have this sort of
entrepreneurial Street where he's like
to the matías era whatever it takes guy
I study the industry I read every single
thing I could on the industry everything
go right out of the gate take off like a
rocket no no no not at all no not at all
because Ron I did I got sued on October
29 this was mental and emotional torture
and I think a little bit of bullying is
good for you guys that make it to the
top somebody bullied them at some point
no one gets bullied more today in the
world in the president excuse the
ultimate counter puncher right I thought
some of the things that were really just
big mistakes would you rather have a
private company spy on you or the
government spy I think the China the
bigger problem is lack of respect for
intellectual property if there is a one
piece of advice you could give to Donald
Trump what do you think that would make
it even more effective
China's quiet that's all I'm saying
hey guys JP here the wolf is in the
house in the Wolves den I am really
excited cuz I have an awesome awesome
guest they said when I respect
tremendously for a number of reasons
short-story emigrated from Iran and the
Revolution fled and I'm playing the [ __ ]
and then serves in the military the
hundred and first aid will out all due
respect I'm Patrick Beth David then came
out built a successful big-time
entrepreneur and became famous from the
was the 92nd entrepreneur had to be
silicon via unbelievable so let's did I
have so much I want to ask you right
first of all about growing up in Iran I
mean it's like one of these are black
holes I always say yeah like from my
movie some I'm a household name a bird
but Iran in North Korea pretty much
right but I think they actually know me
in Iran not North Korea so first what
was it like do you remember and you
probably did you spoke in Iran work a
year ago or something like I was
supposed to speak in Iran and what
happened was it right when Trump got
elected the whole dynamic changed and
the economy crashed and they just it was
disclosed probably not a bad idea I know
that you stayed here but yeah I mean I
remember all I remember living there I
was born October 1878 so revolution
started in 78 and the Shah was an exile
end of January 1979 so I lived there 10
years you know I remember being bombed
on 167 times in a single day one the
stores that is pretty wild were we're
leaving Tehran Tehran the capital wasn't
it like an amazing place not like before
are you kidding completing my seventies
you have Burma
yeah Huber and Iran were the top three
countries in the world for tourism right
right Iran I mean Sinatra is too good
there the why don't they unbeliev a view
to lower it off yes the ambassador of
Iran to us dated Elizabeth Taylor that's
that should tell you something right
there I go what what it was like so sure
I was born to live there ten years war
happened was pretty wild and six weeks
after Khomeini died we escaped we went
to Germany lived there for a couple
years at a refugee camp right an airline
again less charming West Germany
angeles-based that all area absolutely
what so it's a while you're telling me
that so I was right next to military
base and I would always sneak in
and one time we went a little bit too
much you were blowing stuff up but it
was like you shouldn't be here but we
had a great time seeing these guys
blowing stuff up maybe that's one of the
reasons why I got inspired to go into
the military later on what what so you
were there when Khomeini was in powerful
I was yes oh so you were what how old
were you in the showers to post I was
just I was born said no okay there and
no memories of shots you don't know the
minute okay so what was it like when
your life do you remember like was
anything like yeah did you feel
oppressed there or you just young your
Christian rights you know oh yeah all
right is it a problem for you being a
Christian in you know in a very like
sort of what sect is that of Muslim
different sects or yes there are there's
Muslim there's Baha'i there's a lot of
different ones so by the way Baha'i
they're not for Baja as well bhai is
almost like how do I put it imagine like
an LDS or Jehovah to Christianity right
right or how they look Christianity to
Judaism like how Jews look at
Christianity but yeah you know I
remember clearly you couldn't tell
people you were Christian people to ask
me what religion are you said to ask my
dad I don't know that's what we were
told you know you tell people you don't
know what religion you are so you said
what you're like a mixed wait you said
what's the whole give me the whole
family tree because it's a crazy so
mother's side they're 100% communists
they believed in communism their Bible
was Karl Marx that's they swore by Karl
Marx was that
so you know it was this whole idea about
the fact that rich people are greedy all
they care about is money you know they
put people to work and you know they sit
at the table cash two checks big belly
and everybody else is doing the work so
they hated rich people passionately so
basically you're one of those people
that when they say you developed the
beliefs your pairs you go the exact
opposite yeah the exact opposites right
I'm the exact but you might my dad on
the opposite side he said poor people
are lazy so my mom said rich people are
greedy my dad said poor people are lazy
and I'm in the middle by the way all the
debates they had no debate you've ever
seen on television comes closer to place
my mom and dad had I mean it was flying
plates and things breaking it was
entertaining at its best you know what
they say that can you know and calm I
know a lot so I have a great / I did a
Russian girl back you know many years
ago famous Russia's the first Miss
Soviet Union you know her boyfriend's
before me Cirrus Pallavi
it was the Shahs grandson I
sweater guy yeah really yeah she was
engaged to him here was this is 1919 mm
so the late 99,000 we're at the end of
three years hated each other so we made
three as God knows out baby yeah but but
you know the whole thing with Russia was
like they'd say economy is right we'll
keep pretending to work if you keep
pretending to pay me worthless room yeah
this is like the whole like lack of work
no motivations Fred it's like not really
if you can't achieve anything under
communist right so so your so your
mother was basically the idea that you
know everyone should be equal workers of
the world unite right and your dad was
like [ __ ] it that's I don't like lazy
people I want our hundred percent I mean
you said it best just like that a
hundred percent clash of ideas there and
do they stay married
absolutely we got divorced twice they
got divorce after my sister was two
years old and they got remarried then I
was born and then they got divorced 20
years later I don't get that
so like I've been married a few times I
could you marry the same woman again
after she tortures you or vice versa
right I mean wow it's like a
relationship in the Middle Eastern
culture is to guilt aspect of it it's
guilt
you know you know I I can't believe you
did this to her I can't believe you're
leaving her stranded so the guilt gets
in and you see know what maybe i'ma try
this one more time
and so today the second time achamma
absolutely not Oh what broker plates let
me put it to you this way when they got
a divorce when they got a divorce it was
89 91 my debts or the divorce
paperwork's while we were in Germany at
the refugee camp my dad was in u.s. he
served my mom the divorce paperwork
while we're there and my mom got the
divorce paperwork my parents weren't in
the same room for 20 years they weren't
it would not be in the same room for 20
or so I'm getting married and both the
damar expecting to come to my wedding us
you got it what makes it to you coming
to the wedding they said no we're coming
to your wedding I said I'm not doing
this I say here's how we're gonna do it
I need you to come to my apartment
complex this is years ago so I need you
to come to my place
you two need to sit together talk to one
another
and then you'll come to the wedding then
you get the invitation right and I said
we're not doing this I said then that's
no problem you don't need to come to the
wedding so then they call back they said
we'll do it they came to my house it was
the most awkward
hour and a half of them sitting there
but I said as long as you guys are good
then they came to the wedding so 20
years Wow all right so
so you had this like sort of yin-yang
right and then when did you come to the
United States
November 28 1990 okay and so how old
were you then you were 12 12 years old
right and where'd you where'd you settle
Granada Hills Granada Hills California
okay so an hour and a half from here and
what so how was your English English
toffee flawless now so how when you by
the time you guys did you speak English
well from being in West Germany or you
still struggle with it I took EFL which
is English as my fifth language because
you got we got Armenian Assyrian Farsi
German English so your first is Farsi
right versus first is probably Armenian
Assyrian because that's when my parents
spoke right and then as far as because
it's the country I lived in then it's
Germany then it's English yeah I see so
so how proficient that was your English
that when you mean it was not at all so
it's tough in the eye I mean you're some
weddings day right remember Gilligan's
Island yeah I went to school this it so
what kind of shows you watch Gilligan's
Island governament it wishes a pilot is
a tough language right yeah it's not
like cuz it's a lot of silent letters or
listen it's not Syrian when you hear a
Syrian speak you literally think people
are fighting with each other come
careful spyler move out all the stuff is
that you know it's not the most
attractive sometimes you wonder how the
Syrians talk dirty to their girls you
know hey so are you married now I am
married now how long you my for next
week will be 10 years me to 10 years I
have a same woman tell almost 11 years I
met your wife awesome and um kids three
kids three kids seven five and a
three-year-old two boys and a youngest
is a girl alright so let's take this in
a war now right it's okay so you you
come here you're 12 years old right
mm-hmm
no money you know family right yeah no
one's got money right yeah just getting
storing Granada Hills you have to learn
the language right so what did you do we
did you always have this sort of
entrepreneurial streak where you like to
the matter use your or whatever it takes
guy and so you know how did you
transform from that to who you are you
know what's crazy is you know when I was
11 years old in Germany I'm at this
refugee camp and this this one family
comes in
Czechoslovakian family last name is
chaff the the son's name is Yan the
daughter's name is Katerina Katarina was
drop-dead gorgeous she was 10 I was 11 I
knew
since then I'm 11 and I'm looking at
this Chrome like I like this scroll so I
find out yon likes the Super Nintendo
okay so I said okay I'm not a big fan of
Super Nintendo but I'm a fan of your
sister so we got to figure something out
so that summer I went to the local
swimming pool in Germany in airline
again and you know Germany they drink a
lot of beer I said look you know there's
a lot of beer bottles here if I collect
these beer bottles for you and I bring
it to you what are you gonna give me he
says I'll give you five Fenig so the
owner and I broke at the brokered the
deal at 11 years old I calculated how
many bottles I needed which was 5,000 I
brought the bottles to him he gave me
250 marks I went to Cal valve
I bought the Super Nintendo I brought it
back to the refugee camp John played
Super Nintendo I played with his sister
so from the amazing life so much right
never changes I would tell you know in
school I was at one point a GPA kid I
worked I was always tall so I lied on my
age and I wasn't working and telling him
I was 16 17 my first job was at Haagen
Dazs is a 14 year old kid so always
trying to find a way to make money right
and when you have your first real like
so I don't you know working I you know I
guess up to the age I was always an
entrepreneur myself right but and it
really excelled the jump like thank hot
I can't that drove me crazy I worked for
an hourly wage but when did you have
your first like entrepreneurial
experience where you realize that you
know hey I could be in business for
myself doing something stupid like a
lemonade stand do you have anything when
it was the first anchor experience so I
went to school with two backpacks one of
them was books the other one was hats
I would buy from a 99-cent store and
these hats I bought sports teams were
teams that were terrible so like the
Clippers at the time San Jose Sharks the
Mighty Ducks these are no one's gonna
was gonna follow these guys but I would
buy the starter hats for 99 cents and I
would sell them for 7 bucks
and finally my principle cat me and they
said why do you come to school with two
backpacks but your GPA doesn't reflect
the kid that would come to school with
two backpacks so what year is this is
1994 the Clippers sucked by the Clippers
suck back then they had Danny Manning
they could make the playoffs they needed
me to play for their teams and have no
clutch play basketball so weights all
right so that's that by the way it
doesn't surprise me right that you um
you know the buying hats for a buck 99
cents I
I did that on the beach with Isis right
here this class so what you were how old
at that time
1994 15 16 years old so like you know
for me I tell you this I had an
experience when I was 16 years old I
went down to the beach I think you might
know the story right and I started
selling Isis blanket - blanket and the
first day like I made a hundred bucks in
cash and back then and he was
middle-aged she's a bucket of cool I
mean it changed my life in terms of you
know what everything I thought about
money hard work and you know it really
was the really the beginning night stuff
before that but that was the foundation
for who I was because I had that you
know that feeling like when you like
just you know you do something and it
works and you get a pile anyway man like
you know so is that how you felt like
when used to know did you have a bar you
make money doing that was the most you
ever made with the hats you know listen
$100 there was a lot of money yes you
have $100 like are you kidding me oh man
under bucks today dude so what was doing
I'm sorry what you said it was what 95
okay so yeah that's that's like like 250
today probably or you know but also
you're - I can't cuz then you were kid
and you're like wait a minute I can go
buy baseball cards I can go buy
basketball cards the best part for me
was it at the beach money was [ __ ]
singles so it was like it was a 500
bucks hundred-dollar bills this is what
Beach brother owns Beach in New York oka
got it so I was a vendor there and I put
myself through school like that was
reason the money was just the experience
of like you know and I hide three kids
Torf me that she sold puka shells all I
mean I don't [ __ ] thing on but let's
talk about her so she s thought worth
the hats right you have this experience
you're alright now you something to make
money you have a girlfriend at this
point yeah I I was no I don't have a
girlfriend at that point at 96 I had a
girlfriend but not at 95 so you're
making money though and you feel I uh
make your money okay and at this point
now so you know I mean I could only
imagine like you know you show up
speaking a different language right was
it was like my people with the kids nice
to you or did they resent you do they
you know I mean like you know I I would
say it's more making fun of you is what
it was you know the whole your your folk
you know fob fresh-off-the-boat you know
you you don't know how to pronounce the
language a lot of this so it was a crew
you're a big guy right so I mean I think
people be scared yeah but like was it
sort of like was it fun like they were
nice about it were the [ __ ] you know
no absolutely all the [ __ ] yet all
of them yeah you know for me I'll get in
different women I think a little bit of
bullying is good for you I think to get
bully a little bit is at least for me
when I study the guys that make it to
the top
somebody bullied them at some point and
they have a memory of that person or a
chip or something whether it's an older
brother older sibling a friend a coach a
strong father a cousin somebody was a
little bit bullied it could be with
words it could be a lot of different
things so it's interesting you take is
you know it's funny like I mean like I
hate bullies I think as adults we all
hate bullies and pie when you're you
know Airborne Ranger you probably
[ __ ] take the [ __ ] out of any bullies
read about it you know so I guess I
guess you're saying like with it to up
to a point
right like this I get it crosses over to
when it gets really destructive to
someone but I think what you say is a
little bit of like you know you know a
sense of like you know having to sort of
deal with that the world is not a
perfect place well you're gonna be
[ __ ] and sort of develop a little
muscle and you know bit of arm or is not
the end of the world yes so you got to
realize no one gets bullied more today
in the world in the president like okay
so you said there is nobody that gets
bullied more so just thing so here's a
rule that we have in our family when I
sit at night and I talk to my boys my
year five year old of my seven year old
I ask him what do we do as a family
lead respect improve love okay great I
said what do we pray for if you pray
what do you pray for courage wisdom
tolerance understanding great I said do
we bully no do we get bullied no let me
tell you the story of story what
happened here a month and a half ago my
wife calls me she says hey babe Patrick
just got kicked out of soccer practice I
said for what says he punched a kinder
face so let me punch a kick in the face
he punched a kinder face I said come on
I'm Tim I'm telling you baby you're on
speaker talk to him so I said Tico did
you really punch a kid in the face I did
daddy I did punch him in the face why
did you punch him in the face because he
punched me first in the stomach so I
just did what you told me to do I don't
want to get holy I'm all for that so I
called the school I called it a practice
facility and I said listen to
self-defense what happened here and they
said well you know your son kicked the
gear punched the kinder face ass
we kicked them out I said you guys watch
a videotape he says no ice I need you to
watch a videotape because you just
kicked my kid out of practice if he
didn't do it I want to get some war down
and said he'd call me back they said we
apologize your son got punched first
then they react a go so that part of it
to me is you gotta be strong here
because if you're not people will bully
you especially in the business world
when you're coming up you're gonna be
bullied no doubt about it I guess I
guess for me I you know I was fortunate
I wasn't really bullied as a kid but I
know some kids that wore any it's like
you're right you can't be a [ __ ] you
gotta be able to you know stand up for
yourself but kids can be [ __ ] cruel
sometimes you know so I think it's more
recent adults but yeah much worse
especially girls yes I had a daughter
she was like she was a pretty girl when
she got wet had him one year really
tough yeah well like all the with your
don't know we call the girls not liking
her you know they're vicious right so
and she and actually and an interesting
love had changed up for the better so
the valid point you made I think she
realized that like it was a shift for
her that there was a lot more to her
than the way she looked she sort of
focusing on her studies now she just
graduated from NYU grads come on [ __ ]
you know summa [ __ ] laude yeah yeah so I
think your points well today it's the
only thing is like it crosses a line
then it's like it's you know I I don't
think it's good but a little bit I of
you know you can't go through life and
slide through the raindrops yeah give me
an idea when I was in the military okay
if you can't handle sarcasm military's
not for you everything was about sorry
everybody was just poking all the drill
sergeant right hey you got a girl back
at home I do guess what she's doing
right now what's she doing running just
banging Hosea we never do that he's on
top of him right now she's not even
screaming your name yeah so this this
was mental and emotional torture and so
you saw that and you watch your peers
you're like oh my god she can't handle
that he cracked he broke he and a big
part of life is a try out to see if you
can stay strong during these times to
get to the next I firmly believe that
because you go into business when you go
into business I mean nobody liked you
you're like hey what are you doing in
New York who is this guy coming up you
know we don't like somebody coming up
this quick
so someone's gonna try to bully you and
me by the way you know when I always I
was approached by the meta mob a bunch
of times you know and I had private
security forces and stuff back then but
I think the one thing I had going for me
is that because I was under
investigation
[ __ ] scared to getting bombed because
then they would like to get it but your
attention to them but they were on Wall
Street back in the day they were pretty
active trying to muscle the way into
firms and you know and so on and so they
were coming to you oh yeah thank more
than once yes I'm trying to muscle
you're not there to come in and yeah
because listen I was if you think about
it what I was doing was the perfect
money laundering for the mob because III
could essentially make anyone money in a
stop trade yeah and had them take give
me back cash you could actually
legitimize cash true stop and that
happens a lot on Wall Street so you know
I don't know if it happens as much now
because of it's just more difficult with
computers and sort of back in the day
[ __ ] you mean the 60s and since before I
was even there stories were like like
there's so much theft of stock
certificates and she was just like the
[ __ ] Wild West you wouldn't even
believe it right now this is not just
penny stock this is not everything the
whole market before so you know back in
the 60s believe it or not there was no
electronic transfers of securities if
you bought and sold stocks as people
[ __ ] run across the street with
fizzes a little stiff it gets and you
know just just a might say that if you
actually looked to see where those tips
they weren't really there like a lot of
[ __ ] was being stolen and there's stuff
that was back then they will change in
the seventies everything when it was I
think a day cool was one day where
everything went electronic and a lot of
[ __ ] was uncovered but anyway so yeah we
know I did you have pressure at some
point I had a private security guy you
know sort of that I had hired that kind
of intervene but eventually I was on
their investigation say they was scared
to get neck you don't get involved me
guy was it for you in the streets at
that time like when you go to a
restaurant how was the you know when you
were coming up how did the streets treat
you like when other brokers saw you from
Morgan Merrill other place as well and
that was treated well by them because in
the sense that I was like an enigma and
that like you know boiler room right
sure that was not act like that that was
guy worked for me and it wasn't really
accurate in the sense that my guys would
go to a place and get sneered it was
really like that so much
I think they went to the city that much
by the way but but it was really for me
it was more like I was a huge spender
big spender and a lot of friends at the
big of firms so there wasn't like a lack
of respect as much of a lack of
understanding you spent on them at the
big no no no knows what that was it oh
now I was going out into the city yeah
right no way to have big tables and
hookers and drugs and then sadly like
you hate the movie was like almost an
under estimate of what happened right so
the word spread all over Wall Street I
was well-known and I was well like no
one resented it it was like sort of it
was no real clash of world so to speak
it was more like an enigma that was
[ __ ] mine I was like people did it my
drug addiction was I mean you can't you
ever been you don't think you've been
given a drug problem no no I so you know
for years there's like just [ __ ] wild
thing you know I'm saying saw was that
known though oh yeah so they know you
hearted hard dude I would go to
restaurants as a famous restaurant was a
friend of myself walk Packer right he
Owens towel and it very suggest right
here the restaurant called can Estelle's
back and they was just the [ __ ] place
to be right in New York in New York now
19th and Park ok it was a great place
great looking crowd he was an awesome
dude and I would go to carousels and
like beef or ludes deep and just like
balancing off the [ __ ] walls and my
bodyguard no you know Chuck Zito if the
hell head of the Hells Angels he was my
bodyguards he'd follow me around and so
no [ __ ] with me but I was like I was out
of my [ __ ] mind you know and then it
all made sense back then I got soberly
to [ __ ] my Hey look back holy [ __ ] how
long was that about the whole 10 years
ten years it's heavy massive drug use
for about eight solid years of just
massive quaalude use and about three
years a heavy cocaine use right and
that's sort of like you know it just say
like you know cocaine this doesn't
really suit well me it turns me to an
animal I do terrible things and it makes
me into a different I don't want to get
so sexual here but just say it brings
out my perversions
like most men makes us into [ __ ]
beasts of you know whatever we all right
the question I was gonna ask you was a
phone I'm cursin of what you think about
this you know when the first time the
debate was between Nixon and Kennedy
Nixon froze Kennedy didn't and he became
you know everybody's like oh my god this
guy's more present but before that we
in debate that way was radio right so TV
changed the game he can communicate
better which is why Bill Clinton became
president or else George Bush Senior yes
director of CIA with the kind of a
resume you got are you kidding me
awesome there's no way in the world the
governor of Arkansas would have beaten
him if it was just stacked up resumes
who goes against who right so do you
think the current way of social media
marketing access to what we have the way
we see videos on YouTube Facebook
Twitter do you think whoever delivers
the message better wins do you think the
talent plays a very big role to than to
become a new president I think Obama
proved that the power of social media
mobilizing voters and he did a really
great job of that while Romney didn't
write it was a big big deal right I
think Obama did a really good job yes is
yes I mean it's a reality you have to be
savvy Trump is [ __ ] I mean this guy
is you know I thought he was a little I
thought some of the things you were
really just big mistakes and he turned
out to be right like when he went so
hard against the media
he's guys the ultimate counter puncher
right and you know when his tweets me to
call the grandma who says something like
mr. president he got some [ __ ] better
shakin ago like a grandma said one bad
thing is like that [ __ ] grandmother
should go rot in hell she's a loser
to the [ __ ] loser ya know lose a
grandma right you know it's like no one
gets away with it with the guy right but
on some level I I don't know I mean I
you know you can't argue with success
my wife was approached very early on she
was like I like you know she's a Liberty
my wife's a libertarian right and she
was just very Pro chunker's who's more
like the me was more auntie Hitler was
she was she before you approached wrong
oh yeah so you came later on you
supported later on I never was I never
was pro-hillary it was never a shot but
I was I was listen here's the thing so
one when election started you have 16
candidates on the Republican side
who were you except when he would
implode I did not think you did you
think had a chance day one I thought I
thought Jeb Bush would make it was it
because the money on her for the movie I
would buy out I thought that the famine
was pretty corrupt and I thought they
would sort of you know push it through
right but when I was a certain point in
toddler came pretty obvious right and
then when the so he was the interests
the tape came out right with the only
grant the poster and and then he just
went [ __ ] order at them I was like oh
my god this guy but it you know it's a
DIN a different world and you know what
here's what Trump is incredibly great at
he's incredibly good at crystallizing
simple thoughts for people to understand
Roommate America great again he uses
words he repeats them again and again I
personally think that if he improved his
communication like this much he'd be
even more effective but maybe I'm wrong
I don't really know this guy's being
attacked like no other president has
ever been attacked so I wonder what I
would do if I was being attacked as much
as him like I wonder if I would almost
like say if he if the grand MA from
frickin OMA
[ __ ] you grandma you know don't you dare
say I mean because this guy's under
assault
if Trump like if chunk rescued ten
babies out of the oh it's a yeah it he
slaughter the bastards oh he's gonna see
he did it for evil purpose it's pretty
[ __ ] up you know and all I care about
is this I'm very concerned about things
like the budget deficit like this so I
drive real concerns here not for me
honestly things have a way of saying
they kick the can down the road I know I
don't think it's gonna impact our lives
but I think it's gonna impact our kids
lives I think the things that are
happening right now for Millennials and
and that people are coming after I mean
I don't know what the [ __ ] they're gonna
do with this massive deficit that keeps
growing
and they're really concern you it does
concern one part of it the debt we owe
to China or is it more just China told
us a total twenty two trillion debt
because I don't see I think I'm a pretty
smart guy mathematically I don't really
see a way out of it without some
realignment of currency and global trade
meaning if somehow the something
happened with the US dollar but that
would be cool to have a cataclysmic
effect so I don't really see how it ends
the problem is is that you know it's
almost like too big to fail so though
they keep lists they keep printing more
money right and the Fed expands the
balance sheet right and EJ sort of
kicked the can down the road and the I
guess the idea is that if the economy
grows so rapidly then
the tie cutting taxes economy grows
rapidly so that even though it's lower
tax rates the overall intake is much
less the theory and eventually you pay
down the deficit so how much are you
following right now with the 5g thing
that's taking place with Huawei with
China with all that are you following
any us today yeah so what do you think
about that what do you think about the
so let me ask the question in different
way so you got the tariffs that's taking
place right where there is China
obviously Mexico tariff was more about
the immigration in the wall right Canada
tariff was accidental because he was
trying to get it to China he wasn't
really dealing with Canada but this
tariffs is the issue really tariffs to
you is it really 5g is it really what is
the thing that you're most concerned
about biggest thing okay so I think he's
a hundred percent right that the trade
deals that were cut for the US over the
last 20 30 years was just [ __ ]
asinine
I mean honestly both sides all the way
it like it was like it was kind of guilt
like to give away the store like that
right that being said I think with China
the bigger problem is the theft of IP a
lack of respect for intellectual
property and theft of IP and especially
you know high-tech stuff and I think
that's a really major issue so it's not
just about trade imbalances so to speak
that you know they you know and I've
done business in China and I've spoken
in China and and by the way you know one
thing you could say about the Chinese
people the [ __ ] peaceful when did
they attacked anybody never they don't
attack people and so so look at they're
not a military even though they're
building up the military when is China
had committed a warming they've been
attacked they never really attacked
people so they're they're kind of a
peaceful they commit the economic war in
some respect like I've been around
Africa where they're very aggressive in
mind some and they don't always treat
the countries let's say they don't
always in they invest in the country
it's more about grabbing out than
putting back at least that's the
narrative that I hear from countries you
know and I you know I don't have the
proof of it seems like they sort of
pulling out resources not really
building infrastructure so they built
infrastructure that's only robust enough
to last as long as the last piece of
metal comes out there and collapses on
itself right so is that long-term
infrastructure but the big thing I see
with China is that they are stealing
intellectual property and I think that's
the especially in a heart too high-tech
here I think that's the big danger and
without that some check being put into
place and then it's a huge issue
I think the Trump is right and I think
he's the first president to stand
I don't just you know I don't think this
spirals out of control much I really I
maybe I'm wrong
I don't think it's gonna end up in a
full-blown long term trade war I think
there'll be a reset I think they'll come
to terms in within the next six months I
really do think so I think so
I think what what do you think would be
the cornerstone of that taking place
like what's gonna cause that well I
think it won't he had a classic
statement by the way it was like he said
to the to the Democrats like almost like
could you at least [ __ ] lie for me
and pretend to be on my side so I can
negotiate more effectively like a lot of
what Trump does is posturing and
negotiating and threatening and basic
negotiations right you have to kind of
see through some of his tactics right
and I I don't believe I think he's smart
enough to know you know but I know
minutiae and I met him before in person
he's not surrounded by idiots he's
surrounded by smart people everyone
knows that you know that tariffs over
the long term really are not a good
thing okay but that being said you know
as a short-term punitive measure as in
the goshi ating tack that I think it's
important I think he's doing the right
thing because you can't I don't think
was sustainable with China what they
were doing was is there essentially
exporting like crazy putting up barriers
they have tire they have barriers to
import they're right and if you want to
do business there you have to
essentially have it's gotta be an
operated by Chinese company and that
means your technology comes openness
from technology the hole made in 25a
made in China nine 2025 plan that's a
heck problem so what do you think about
the whole speed of 5g the fact that EU
u.s. South Korea Australia is not gonna
have a ready till 2025 and China
ascender gonna have it ready by 2020 I
think that number one the 5g rights
based on the phones have to be rate
Apple won't even have a throne ready I
think until 2020 right so like right now
on my phone I have this thing it's
called
5g is an [ __ ] scam 5ge you know what
it's called yeah evolutions nothing it's
nothing is 4G one day I'm like what the
[ __ ] do you it must come from right here
so from what I heard right there roll
a couple of cities this year I think the
mass adoption is next year right that's
supposedly with my China no new s the
u.s. is next year I u.s. is saying
they're not gonna be ready 5g till 2025
really because I read an article is that
Trevor an article had said that they
were testing it I thought in 19 cities
and yet in that small cities they may
run around either challenges the
challenge you're having is with the
trees mmm because it's not going through
trees so China the way they came out
with the 5g biggest concern to have
would fight G right now it's us
if we land 5g contract because we got 4G
that increased GDP by a hundred billion
dollars they're projecting 5g technology
of us gets at first as three million
jobs and half a trillion dollars of GDP
goes up if we get 5g and so a big part
of this when you're looking at is saying
you know Trump is a pretty brilliant
negotiator why is he banning Huawei is
he banning Huawei because they
potentially could come into the US
economy and compete and take some of the
market share away from Apple you got
three poster chance for each country you
got Apple as US Samsung as South Korea
Huawei is China
so I think the problem with what Wally
said francois that's the right way yeah
well we hallway okay so the problem with
that I think originally was that that
the there was a suspicion that they were
embedding code in they're applying
they're following of computers that
would allow China to basically spy tap
in so there's a big issues which started
with not allowing it to be involved in
government organization that's how it
starts right
and then it's spread from there right so
I think that that's the big concern is
that there is things going on with their
technology their embeddings number I
wouldn't be shocked me I think the
Chinese are surveillance critic it's a
culture if you go to you know you go to
if you been to China recently no [ __ ]
they have [ __ ] they're like they have
technology all over this [ __ ] cameras
and [ __ ] like facial recognition stuff
like I saw this thing it's like almost
like the future were like they can track
you like in real time they read this
thing when a guy commits a crime it was
like a mock thing and the police caught
the guy like within 15 minutes goes like
they tracked the guy fieri so it's
[ __ ] like Minority Report like in
that movie right it's crazy so let me
ask you this but do you think
us cuz you know your iPhone has 900
million active phones right added an 900
million active phones 300 million
roughly is out of China
don't you think China can assess what
wait a minute you're spying on us
through Apple don't you think they can
potentially say well what maybe us is
China you know spying on us why don't
you so worried about us you know spying
on you is a good question so I think
that the perception and by the way us
you know who [ __ ] knows I'm not a
tech guy I'm not a coder I [ __ ] about I
have coders here right yeah I always
[ __ ] when I walk by and I say oh you
left out a [ __ ] coal in there but now
I see it on this screen it's like the
[ __ ] matrix right you know like what
are you doing you left out an apostrophe
yeah it's a bucket thing never working
on these guys are brilliant young guys
right in the code and stuff and it's
something that I never want to learn
right it's like I came too late it's
born too early for that [ __ ] right but I
think that who knows what backdoors and
trap doors the thing is the difference I
believe is that is much more
transparency in the US and maybe I'm
[ __ ] naive okay maybe Froy oh the NSA
has got a trapdoor built here every
[ __ ] phone and listen you know this
you know about the whole thing with the
sucks net virus they put around the
world with Israel they did to like get
people's electrical you know I would
always say like you know what my problem
with the whole Russian meddling thing
was I was like a [ __ ] medal and
everyone I think this [ __ ] so Russia's
meddling uh what elections we go back to
Iran Mogadishu right install people in
all over the world I don't think that's
a terrible thing like Louis has a
foreign policy and you know they're
actually eggs trying to exert their will
so this will be a Russian like we're
trying to interfere no [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're trying to interfere with our
election they've always try and I think
we always try to do it around the world
too so I don't think it's like the end
of the world I think what happened was
frankly it's the old [ __ ] the best
defense is a good offense cuz Hillary
did the dirty dossier
she says [ __ ] let's deflect it away from
me because I had this done by you know
fusion GPS with Fricke Christopher steel
so let's just say Trump colluded with
Russia because this takes the burden off
me but now it's boomeranging back so I
don't really be scary THAAD right
there's a very secure minica so then you
said then would you rather have a
private company spy on you or the
government spy on you if you had a
choice a private company because
really profit baby [ __ ] that
everybody looked at it that which is
intuitive I answered it intuitively but
that's your right because you know I
guess like their own selfish interests
like a person so much in its relation
they wanna Buxbaum that's it tell me
[ __ ] put the right things in front of me
I get nervous about we sit me laughs
like will my wife and I will talk about
something and next day it's [ __ ] like
on my like advertising like oh my god I
I got nervous I turned off my Alexa I
know it's probably stupid but I turned
the [ __ ] a [ __ ] I got nervous like yeah
I was like what the [ __ ] it's just woman
listen and you know what like and here's
the thing right there is gonna be a
point and I think it's coming soon we're
like artificial intelligence really is
gonna your lats moment of singularity
take all right I think Raymond Kurzweil
was coined that term maybe he didn't but
this idea that computers will become
more powerful than people and then who
knows the [ __ ] gonna happen then right
but you think about it yeah every and
we're so I rely on it I'm sure you do
too right my phone right we're all over
right man and it's a scary thing because
you you are I mean think about before so
back in like it's not that long ago when
like we were in a not non digital world
like I grew up in a non digital world
you know it used to be a great thing
you'd wait you probably remember this
one it was like you were younger and you
wait for a movie to come on TV there's a
big deal like on you know be in the
theaters and if you missed it that you
wait two years and you see it like a
Sunday night is a and now it's an
instant dis yeah it's like a different
front world right you know and and
here's the another thing so like there's
always unintended consequences for a lot
of stuff like Anand for example it's
social mean you brought it up it's a
good point so what do you think that
sucks we don't know you know on some
level it's great because on one point it
gives every person a voice but it also
gives every [ __ ] a voice right
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there but
here's the thing I think the problem is
more the algorithms that companies like
Facebook use where they show you more
and more of what you like so you end up
in a [ __ ] echo chamber and I really
wish that I wish our I I you know I
sometimes I'm starting to really not
like my newsfeed because it's the same
[ __ ] I don't want to see people always
with me I want to lose every day I to I
read the New York Times
I'll watch I don't want to see an X it's
[ __ ] nonsense right but I'll watch
one of the regular mainstream news
channels and I'll watch Fox News because
I want to see both so I don't want to
hear what everyone is saying I don't
want to be an echo chamber what happens
on social media is though if you start
clicking on certain things over you
likes that they show you more of that
and before you know it it's a almost
bombs disagree you don't like that I
don't like that I want you know they're
trying to change our other way I think
it's the promise to put you an echo
Jimmy you start to think everyone agrees
with you and they don't there's a lot of
pizza there's a lot of really smart
people who are liberal out there really
normal smart people I don't agree with
them I'd love to debate with them about
it but people are entitled to have their
views and have healthy debate and what
happens with social media is that you
end up in an echo chamber and that's
dangerous where you only sing this [ __ ]
and I've seen it happen myself my wife's
newsfeed and she had it most attached
because she ended up in this ultra
conservative buy and not buy by choice
by accident that's a big problem yeah
it's gonna be funny to see what takes
place here moving forward what do you
think about so many things in terms of
the next election how what do you how do
you think social media plays into the
upcoming election well I mean I think
Ron Paul changed the game I think it's
all about Ron Paul Ron Paul changing him
in oh four oh four he raised six million
dollars on myspace in 24 hours was a
Guinness Book of World Record Ron Paul
69 year-old man raises six million
dollars on myspace in 24 hours Obama
sees this saying if this guy can raise
six million dollars in 24 I'm all raised
two billion dollars to be a president
become a two-term president look what
happened right so I think it's gonna
play a very big role and it's funny how
Facebook is facing so much backlash now
where they're being forced to be more
transparent and people are upset to say
that hey facebook is now going to show
what Trump's campaign is gonna be doing
all this stuff and they're kind of being
open about it because they're forced to
do that and Trump's kind of holding them
accountable a lot of people are meeting
with Facebook to see are you guys gonna
be open or not but I don't think it's
gonna be much different look at look at
this you know a couple guys that are
coming up on the Democrat side right
they're coming up to become candidates
they're just doing social media better
than Andrew yang is coming out and over
this guy's tell my universal basic
income saying let's give everybody a
thousand dollars a month one and a half
trillion
your mom is gonna improve the economy
let's just braid money and serve it or
not right you think about that I think
it's [ __ ] the most stupid thing on
the [ __ ] art I mean I mean you don't
listen you matter what life is very and
some things are very simple if you give
people something for nothing they don't
[ __ ] value it okay it's the same
thing with you know I sell information
products right if you under price
something I've actually tried it on I
want to be a nice guy I'm gonna just
give this away very cheap people won't
use it because they don't invest their
money they don't know whatever they're
not and they're not invested in it right
versus charging a higher price and
people say oh [ __ ] up but money like I
better do this and I think by you know
giving people monies is idiotic okay you
know I I always like always my parents I
grew up in a very liberal house all
right obviously had very different views
to my parents growing up but they're
growing up oh my god yeah growing up
from as far back I love ASM so it caused
it I'll tell you someone back when I was
12 my brother he's a [ __ ] economy
right and he went to this camp that was
like a communist [ __ ] camp right now
you're eyelines my older brothers I want
to go to the camp do it you really know
what it was a battles like a socialist
[ __ ] work camp right so I go there
right and I and I and they say okay
first thing you gotta do is you gotta
share you got to put your money in I'm
like why because we all pull our money
like they're gonna say that yeah
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm like I don't
wanna do that they [ __ ] in I gotten
punished
they put me in a [ __ ] like a lockdown
situation like because I wouldn't share
my [ __ ] money and I was acting Oh
screaming why the [ __ ] should I share my
money with other people like you know
it's like and was it not that I think I
even worked for cuz I was already doing
magic shows but I was like so I SOPA
they threw me out I actually got I gotta
leave the camp early I got thrown out
and like and so I always just fall back
as I can remember I always like nice
things
I always was not scared to work for nice
things and I think when my parents were
amazing people love my parents to death
but I noticed some things about them
like number one brilliant hardworking
educated and [ __ ] broke
so like what wait a second okay wait so
a it says here you can go to school get
degrees they both the CPAs my mom's not
even a lawyers mom and dad was super you
both CPA my mom was a CPA back in the
fifties like in Mad Men
when women weren't in the workplace
right she was there and you're hearing
the food oh yeah and she was rocking and
rolling brilliant woman right my dad was
a CPA and I remember when I was like 11
years old I wanted a dirt bike and I
said hey I'm on a dirt bike might like
120 bucks so they said we can't afford
it I'm like what if [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what do you mean they're like you guys
are [ __ ] accountants what do you mean
you can't afford like we get my mom says
let me show you our budget and she
actually showed me the fee I was like
[ __ ] I was appalled I was like that's
all you [ __ ] me I was like I felt like
how old did you say you were 12 you let
11 or 12 so like that right and they
couldn't and it couldn't have this dirt
bike and the same thing I was an
electric guitar I want to play the
guitars get a Whitney Lane and I was
like [ __ ] and it just sort of you locked
in this idea with me that there's
something else now let's do the
Entrepreneurship right you're if you're
a really well-known well-respected
entrepreneur we could talk all day to to
us right but I won't talk about
entrepreneur should tell me about how
you you had a big break right well you
wait so you'd order the army your
[ __ ] madman right you that I respect
you
anyone that serves the military's I just
[ __ ] kudos for you right that's great
right I really not really I mean that
from the bottom I want right but then
you come out right and tell me your
career and it really slows it off yeah
so I got out I yeah meta I want to be
body builder that's what it was I was
gonna go be the Middle Eastern or no
that was gonna go when mr. Olympia going
to Hollywood Mary Kennedy be governor
that was a plan right that's that's the
rod I was gonna take met a girl at
Venice Beach California she was a broker
at Morgan Stanley Dean Witter okay
and we'd go out she would also pick me
up in a different car and finally I said
how do you make your money she says I'm
the advisor to Laker players that's what
I do I'm a series 766 the whole nine I
said how can I do it she said well you
need to have a four-year degree Morgan
doesn't hire without a degree and I was
looking for JT Marlin but JT Marlin
wasn't out there so I said how do I
start work a boiler room replica look
for these guys see if I can find
something so I took my resume
undercover the resume I put a joke and
on the bottom of the joke I put a few if
you're laughing right now this is
exactly how clients are gonna feel when
they invest with me if you want someone
like this part you didn't give me a call
bother my resume had the following
haagen-dazs Bob's Big Boy Burger King
military Bally's that's what no
four-year degree no two-year degree come
on military helps out yeah yeah I was 21
years old I fax a 200 different places
30 people call me back 15 said this is
hilarious but you don't qualify 15 gave
me an interview and eventually I got
three offers I started off with Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter out of Glendale so
so 9/11 happens at day before 9/11 my
first day with Morgan Stanley Dean
Witter this is a Monday 9:10 start off
with them get my series 766 31:26 life
and health I go that route and starts
Allen next thing you know I go to
Transamerica I'm with them for seven and
a half years then October of oh nine we
start on an insurance company sixty-six
agents out of Northridge California
sixty-six agents notice car insurance
come fall e October overnight
I am thirty at the time okay so I look
at the marketplace I said okay no one's
using social media and financial
services they're afraid of it they're
worried about it because you can use it
you can't post anything everything we'd
be teas got to get approved
broker-dealers on how to prove in these
emails all these things they're talking
abut life is still flexible but
securities is not I said let's go
through life so we eliminate a lot of a
securities gig and restrict Li focus on
life and annuities so we start off out
of one office Northridge California and
the next thing you know we grew from 66
Asians to today ten thousand five
hundred agents 49 states
De La Hoya is one of our investors
Gabrielle Brenner's another one Atalaya
fund out in New York is another one it's
a two billion dollar fund we raise it
our conventions coming up in the next
six weeks keynote speakers building we
got a stop yeah I gotta go back this is
you have to tell okay you owe it to my
to my people here how the [ __ ] did you
do I want to know hey let's break down
your strategy right if you could let's
break it down so like I always think
that like while it might seem like kind
of [ __ ] that this guy do it like it's
an in the end is always you did some
things that are duplicatable strategies
100 percent let's just slow it down so
tell me what was easy you started in
2009 2009 in October of 2008 a cure
sought to $600,000 six
you borrow a to-20 euro much you took
the money you earned it from financial
services you roll the [ __ ] now is
that like your last dollar you had more
did you like put it on the line don't
you have some more in reserve I probably
had a little bit more but I put I said
I'm going all-in
you put the bulk of your mom up the bulk
of my money in annual how old at the
time
twenty-nine thirty okay and married at
this point I got married three months
prior to that no kids yet no kids got
okay good great time right a lot of
people watching or in that they do you
can it's almost as you get a bit old you
can always you know do things in life
when you're that age no kids you [ __ ]
can't afford to take risk right yeah so
we let me tell what happened though that
you asked the question strategy that's
gonna be transferred to other people
this is one of them I studied the
industry I literally sat down and I read
every single thing I could on the
industry everything limb raw every
reports demographic we are able to
recruit who they're not what clients are
getting not getting any kind of service
so I looked at the whole Do Not Call
list is it doing good things for the
marketplaces they're doing bad things
for the marketplace when it came out in
November of oh three I'm looking at
everything the average agent at the time
was a 57 year old white male today the
average agent is a 59 year old white
mouse I'm looking at the market oh yeah
insurance I'm looking at the market they
don't know how to tap into the Latino
community there is no they don't know
how to tap into women selling insurance
it's mainly men selling insurance they
don't know how to tap into Millennials
they're not fully understanding social
media they're afraid of social media
shall wrote a book I wrote a book about
specifically what our strategy was says
was 5 points so step one in other words
you didn't just leap you you actually
did some research you identified and
niche in the marketplace and you had a
strategy your model someone and then or
you know typically like you know if
there's a some model that you use then
you improved on it or was it basically
it was your model the culmination of all
your research no I mean my model was a
model of five different people that I
looked at what I was watching well he
took what you like from one from another
one not absolutely I would say what but
what book had a big impact on my own my
business was blowing strategy absolutely
okay I mean blue I don't know if your
revolution started you know highly
recommend rate it a hundred percent
recommend specially now you do in your
podcast and what you highly highly
recommend the blue ocean strategy
formulas if they make a note four and a
half million copies sold
WC Chen you will not be able to put it
down right so I read the book and I'm
like okay this strategy makes a lot of
sense so we need to eliminate we need to
decrease increase create perfect this is
what it's making this the direction
we're gonna go and I looked at an
insurance at the top everybody was
Caucasian we need some people that can
connect with Millennials and minorities
and that's the direction we're going so
we started going by the way today we're
54 percent Latino and 51 percent women
our number-one earner is a woman and she
started like we started with how many
agents 6666 had you start with 66 people
I was already known in the marketplace
in the Sanford and you know San Fernando
Valley area so you opened up your dog
imagine New York is San Fernando ok in
San Fernando they knew what I was doing
so you opened up yet 60 desks with
agents there are they working for you
although they were just office 60 ages
60 and look at it as a co-op banker you
got 60 Realtors working with you got it
yeah God okay that's 66 agents all right
and you took you took those from people
knew you in the industry so yeah
basically Heather guys I had trained for
seven and a half years she had a balance
you know how to follow it now okay so
you start with 66 agent and does it just
like right out of the gate take off like
a rocket no no no no not at all because
right I did I got sued on October 29th
of 2009 from a four hundred dollar
company Hague on October 24 what for
potentially taking clients we didn't
take any clients seven thousand clients
stayed interfere we must interfere yes
August which is nine ten months later we
settled I've never been sued in my life
that was the only time I got sued so I
could say that keep god yeah so August
we settled we finalized we started
moving and from there some you know the
strategy was I'm gonna start with
California then I'm gonna go floor down
then I'm gonna go Texas then I'm gonna
go Illinois then I'm gonna grow and
expand right so we went one office two
three four five six and now we're over
100 offices nationwide
well what was your you say your biggest
pivot like you had to make you know
typically when you're doing that you're
you know you make your starting and
things going oh you made some little
move and it just was there one move that
you made not a per se was that kind of
oblivious that question yeah so I was I
was a so I'm sitting there and I'm
looking at the comp plan and a company's
calm structure attract certain kind of
people your company whatever way you pay
your people house in person it attracts
exactly so I'm looking at it saying what
kind of people does this comp plan
attract I change my complemented times
maybe a hundred temp could be even more
I kept changing we're changing this this
month we're test extract test test test
finally I came out with this a comp plan
in September I don't know what September
of 14 or 15 15 I want to say September
and I called it the great equalizer
bonus program and it was five tiers and
I'm gonna try to for one month then two
months and three months the next thing
you know a guy that had only been with
us for a year made 220 then six-forty
than a million alright and he made 3.3
million for in two and a half three
years and it was like wait a minute what
Ella so then everybody followed this
comp so the way you setup the comp gets
to behavior that you want there are a
lot of companies do not agree with you I
receive by the way when I you know I do
a lot of consulting write for sales
puzzles say some of the biggest mistakes
are made in the compensation because if
you have a confidence flawed it
disincentivizes people to work or just
to have a few clients so stop right so
you have to almost make sure that
someone just can't open a few big
clients and rest on their laurels right
and then unlike wise also you want to
have people that are tied to the company
you built Lori with residual income
right so so this is kind of dance you
doing with both so you run you hit on
this comp plan right people start making
a lot of money they just almost not like
pouring in it's just showing up your
daughter for work basically yeah and
then at the same time in 2013 I was a
private gun like listen I'm not gonna
talk about my belief you know communists
of how was raised Iran all this I'm I'm
private guy I live my life I'm gonna
work I'm gonna do my thing libertarian
leave me alone let me make my money just
don't bother me I kind of started
noticing that we're living in a time
where everybody's naked you can't hide
today it takes two minutes for somebody
know you're Republican that's all you
got to go on your Twitter account
Facebook account okay this was Jordan
Belfort's believes and got it next but
right so I said rather than trying to
live a private life I'm gonna start
creating content so I was making content
strictly privately for our agency but I
started doing it publicly right started
a YouTube channel called that Patrick
made David two years later change it to
value taemin and today we got 1.3 1.4
million subscribers over a billion
minutes watch tell me this this there's
one thing I read yeah this one
major eight right the ninety was the
NATO was on face tell me that this is
the night yes so you know I put the
video on YouTube it's always high a life
of an entrepreneur ninety seconds
alright that was a [ __ ] box as soon
as I heard I'm like bingo that's like
just a catchy title right yeah yeah so
tell me what was it yeah so we put the
video up and what's so crazy the day we
shot the video is the day my
father-in-law died and I went inside my
wife is crying and I'm like I gotta
cancel this shoot I don't even know how
to handle my one I've never seen my wife
lose you know her father so she's a mass
she's I said I'm not shooting she says
no babe you go do your thing guys at the
camera guys eight people are outside six
o'clock in the morning you know we're
trying to set this whole thing up she
says no go do it under you guys I'm
planning this that's okay so we want a
shot I'm just like I'm a mess the entire
day my mind is under family so I'm
shooting and we came back these guys did
a phenomenal job we put the video up on
YouTube I said let's see how it's gonna
do we called it the best motivational
video 2015
I love it I go to sleep I wake up it's
only two thousand views what a flop so
then we go uploaded October 31st at 3:13
p.m. Pacific Standard Time I uploaded on
Facebook tidal life of an entrepreneur
90 seconds and then we go out there what
he called a Halloween trick-or-treat oh
my kids right two hours later he's got
300,000 views I go to sleep wake up 5
million views a week later 10 million
and and all of us on 31 million views so
it's it just went crazy
that's a it's a great feeling isn't it
you know it's like just when you don't
expect I know it's a defining moment
right then you took that right and then
you ended up lever to get to a book
right I leveraged the two books all in a
the book was life of an entrepreneur 90
pages 90 pages great and I'm sure the
book was a huge bestseller we did well
it did the book that well yeah and in
terms of your business did it impact
your business percent was it a separate
thing I your is your personal brand
integrated into your business No so
here's what I don't do you will never
hear me do a call to action with my
following to go into what I'm doing
personally never you will never hear me
matter of fact let me give you what took
place a month ago I told the vault the
value team of followers I'm gonna put a
three-day conference once we cross a
million subs so we cross a million steps
and
put a three-day conference in Dallas we
had two months to promote I said we
didn't do it in Dallas to my agency in
the insurance company I said you are not
allowed to come so I put a conference
the following week I rented out the
Cowboys Stadium I've put a conference
the following week so it wouldn't you
know kind of confuse each other so value
Tim and audience was one week then the
PHP audience was a following week we had
people shelf on 43 different countries
to the vitamin conference and it was
great three-day comprar had Peter Guber
there I had Phil Heath there I'm it was
a great conference Sean our conference
PHP is five weeks from now have
President Bush there I have Kobe Bryant
come in Jordan that's gonna be the one
in five weeks that's tomorrow so yeah
it's it's I've separated the two because
I want the integrity of both that's work
very well and and it both audiences have
a lot of respect that there's no
commingling going on two questions were
over I'm gonna go from a minute leave
the way over but you're interesting to
do I love talking to you so I'd love you
to come back again um a couple questions
number one for a young entrepreneurs
Yeah right what's the what's the best
thing I'm not like what industry reaches
just what's the advice that you would
give like you know to a young guy 2025
years old right wants to go out get rich
get and build the great life but what
advice just overall advice would you
give them it's very easy for me it's
shadowing go shadow somebody go shadow
somebody is good all right well not just
proximity proximity is hey Jordan can I
take you out to lunch and spend time
with you
that could be proximity I'm talking
about sticking by hey and can I work for
Jordan be your right-hand guy be a the
movie American Gangster you see Frank
Lucas sees his boss shadows them for 10
years then he becomes you see this in
business you see this in sports you see
this Steve Kerr is shadow and Phil
Jackson then he shadows Popovich now
he's the best coach in the NBA outside
of Popovich there's an element of
shadowing so you gotta find somebody
locally where you say look I want to go
work for this guy and I'm gonna spend
three years with this guy learn from him
so the idea is that let's say you know
you're what you're a born entrepreneur
right you know it's in your blood
yeah but as part of that like there's a
certain period of sacrifice to really if
you find the right
so they could like it you could really
you know kind of really tap into right
and really learn from a growing there's
nothing wrong with spending a certain
amount of time they're really those
grooming years right a lot of people
skip over that they don't they don't
want to sit there and kind of beasts
absurd someone else they even feel
something if you're like you know
there's an entrepreneurial mindset too
don't work for someone else but they're
not mutually exclusive those it's okay
to do it if there's an end game in mind
right you're you know you're not looking
your lifelong service yeah but to tap
into whatever your needs but then
eventually when the time is right and
you know what you need to know you have
the connections of respect you go out in
your own yeah absolutely I'm all about
you if you shadow the right person you
shadow the right person and then for me
get to a point where you can have a
power position with this person get to
point we can talking to the person
that's absolutely ambitious driven I'm
not talking to the guy that's I get it
wants to do a role-playing type of
position I'm talking somebody says I
want to go be somebody and I'm gonna go
make tens if not hundreds chase the big
dollars but I want to be able to do it
with somebody you find like a lot of
times somebody goes and works for a guy
who's doing very well he's known in the
community say the who ever of different
cities every city has somebody that
everybody wants to work for you go work
for that guy then it comes to a point
where like I'm gonna go do my own thing
it may not make sense for you to go to
your own thing there's a lot of people
right now being billionaires being
entrepreneurs not entrepreneurs in
certain industries by the like financial
certain to infrastructure it's easier
absolutely no doubt about absolutely
even Ballmer look what bombers worth you
know thirty forty billion dollars he
never started anything he worked with
gate so positioning is critical knowing
where your strengths are you know this
whole idea about I can be that guy you
can't be everybody you gotta know very
early you cannot be everybody there are
certain people you and I cannot be like
there are certain personality training
no doubt no doubt about it so the sooner
you want identify your own strengths in
accepting it yes so style like I like
let's just say if I relate to your style
I'm like you know what I'm like your
style then I got to work for a guy like
you say different style of selling you
go look at a guy style sell and that's
very proper you know very good you got
to go to that guy somebody that fits
your style that's killing it then go
shadow that person and a few years later
you can make some decisions on where you
want to go I think that you know one of
the things is
and to point out with that is that when
you when you're modeling someone you
don't have to necessarily take every
aspect of them you can extract very true
best right because I made that mistake
because you're right I've done that and
I did that and actually had some guys
amazing traits but he had some bad ones
too and I didn't realize I was young and
naive and I took sort of the whole
organism you can actually have one two
three people and it said you did five
you said you're five entities and you
sort of pulled the best from each one
starred your company pivoted a couple of
times boom took off so I think the key
is is that when you do what you said
exciting is a great thing to do but you
don't have to always take everything
from someone you could take only the
best traits and the ones that fit you in
sort of leaves because no one's perfect
everyone's got that flaws and stuff oh
yeah I mean listen one of the best
advices I got many many years ago was
you know sons and fathers or daughters
and mothers go through three phases
first day idolize then they demonize
then they humanize so idolize demonize
humanized oh my gosh my dad's my hero
dad you're an [ __ ] you know nothing
you don't even understand what I'm going
through
oh my gosh my dad's not perfect is he
human being just like me so yeah anybody
you work with you're gonna go through it
and the goal is to eventually get to the
humanized face because no one is gonna
be perfect and last question right what
do you think about 2020 what do you
think is gonna win and you know how do
you view and what like these are concern
you if the country takes a rapid lurch
to the left only no what do you think
Scranton if you look at the pendulum
just go I'm I'm a trend guy I'm a data
predictive analytics guy this is what
I'm bring you in Billy Beane to our
conference because I want to know that I
love baseball cuz its stats right I'm a
stats guy so president today's
Republican okay Trump prior to him Obama
Democrat prior to him Bush Republican
prior to Clinton democrat prior to him
Bush Republican prior to him like you
know you can go Reagan and then Carter
and then Nixon and then so you can go
back and look at Ford and Nick's lion
John it's two terms versus one exact
right so if you're asking a two-term
question I don't think the left has got
a solid candidate I don't think Joe
Biden is going to be able to face off
with Trump I don't see that I think
Bernie Stan
a better debate than him debate wise
remember not full of philosophy I think
Biden may be a better Democratic
president than Sanders would but today
personality matters energy matters being
able to move and rally you know every
time Biden was an Iowa didn't show up to
his hand but but Sanders know how to
rally people so Sanders was even better
at rallying than Hillary well know that
one listen you know she was a flawed
delegate he had it though the other
super that was stolen basically let me
ask you a question if there's one last
question right I got that you're a smart
guy right if there was a one piece of
advice you could give to Donald Trump
that this is one thing you could change
what do you think that would make him
even more effective one thing that he
would change what style one what is
anything that you would change or now
here's here's what I would tell you I I
okay so for me it is very hard to give
advice on personality that's worked for
somebody for 74 flippin years there's
nothing you can tell this guy he's gonna
sit there and say do you know how many
broads I've been with you know how many
billions I've touched do you know how
many people have had dinner with do you
know what kind of building you have no
clue who the hell you are to give me
advice with you I really think he's not
a guy that takes advice from anybody I
believe that I don't think he's an
advice guy I think he processes with
people like I think home picks was a
good process I think Sarah Huckabee was
a good person
I think Kelly onaconda was a good person
to listen to him but so he takes it in
and uses own internal mechanism I will
give one thing there's one thing I will
say I will give one thing that in this
negotiation that he's doing I think he's
starting to realize the power of 5g
because what it's gonna do to
self-driving cars and what it's gonna do
to speed up technology and we're gonna
come up with technology better in the
fact that Huawei out of 188,000 employs
75,000 of their employees are in R&D
research and development we are this
this 5g things gonna be bigger than
people realize it so you know I'm glad
you brought this up great I have not
focused enough on I'm aware of it right
but I'm actually gonna research because
it's a very rethink of the denial I said
of your time yeah your brain the way
your wire like the way you explain
Bitcoin like them your brain the way
you're what if you go down the rabbit
hole of where I'm going
you are good you it's gonna be like 50
layers and it's deeper thing by the way
today the CEOs doors and she still under
she's no she was Mengele right she's at
arrested II she's still there I she was
they really know she's back but Google
dropped the contract there's no right so
the most important number there is 206
million phones were sold last year while
way they went from 0 to 206 million in
ten years they've never sold smartphone
they started in 1987 first time they
sold a smartphone was 2009 206 million
they sold last year added to Turner six
million 105 is in US 105 is in China 101
is outside Google said we're not letting
use the operating system so they're
going to yeah yeah so now they're
designing their own opera so they have
to be very as he's negotiating right now
with China and using all of this stuff
he can probably bully Mexico that he's
doing a little bit and Mexico needs
America tremendously China has got 1.5
billion people and if they all a sudden
come out and I know Tim Cook was with
Trump a few days ago thought they all of
a sudden come out and say listen we're
banning something you're doing as well
if they come and play that same game and
Huawei is projected according to
Business Insider it's dropping 30 to 40
percent of revenues this year projected
they did 108 billion last year they
could drop 30 to 40 billion of revenues
this year Huawei if was president ren
who is friends with the prime minister
of China because ren used to be part of
the chinese government military if he
goes there and says listen look what
just happened here and they retaliate
against apple little bit of this
bullying tactic trump is using could
backfire on the economy and then if the
economy like if hillary wanted to play
minute manipulative game today here's
what i would be doing if hillary wanted
to play like the whole dasya she wrote
this is what I'd be doing if Hillary
wanted to play her manipulative game she
would go to China try to figure out a
way to convince them to ban any China
companies from doing business with Apple
hurting US economy by 20% because Trump
can no longer use look what the economy
is doing today versus when I first got
started
if Trump cannot use the economy cart he
doesn't get reelected yeah you know what
I think I I think my guess is you know
back in like the days of rush when you
said this thing called mad mutually
assured destruction
I have a suspicion that cooler heads are
gonna prevail here because China doesn't
want an economic wall because they
they're trying to elevate so many people
up out of poverty I've been there right
you know you know back in the 80s it was
the story was Japan's gonna take over
the world Japan Japan Japan the Rising
Sun the movie right and there's the
[ __ ] hat but it was exam there's
little populations there not recent
there enough yeah right but you know but
but my there's something that tells me
that there's a little bit of puffery
like you know you heard about the empty
cities being built and you know like
this you know not everything is always
what meets the eye and I think that
honestly I think both sides need each
other hundred percent yes I don't
there's no big that my guesses at the
end of the day maybe I'm wrong I think
cooler heads will prevail I hope so I'll
say they'll say this final thoughts for
you to be thinking about this one I had
a friend very quiet guy I was telling
the story to fit while we're driving up
here it was five for 150 pounds I love
it right it was so loose they would sell
one night it's 3 o'clock in the morning
we're in the parking lot and a guy pulls
up the car and he turns off that we're
living in a bad community I thought he
pulls up the car turns off the lights
points a gun at us he says hey Holmes
who you what you do in Mato and then he
looks at me says oh [ __ ] what's up ad I
said the guy knew who I was but he
points a gun at my friend Sal
and my friends uten my friend said you
don't pull a gun at me I don't care who
you are he says get out of the car says
no I say we're good he says no get out
of the car so I'm not gonna punch you in
the car he gets out of the car he says
let me know when you're ready just let
me know when you're ready
he tells him warning let me know when
you're ready that we're gonna fight
he says I'm ready he beats the living
[ __ ] out of this guy he's bouncing his
head off the ground scraping his face oh
here's a moral of story saw was a quiet
guy very quiet at the hwachun don't talk
to him China's quiet that's all I'm
saying so you don't want to get them to
the point where China but they're
peaceful but you don't cry if you go too
much there's no one that's gonna take
too much so all I'm suggesting is maybe
if I so rolling is all I'm saying
dude you're a [ __ ] legend I
appreciate that
I'm back to the Batman all right it's a
pleasure good to be here thank you